the Resident Evil franchise has a
sprawling timeline that interweaves its
complex narrative across seven mainline
games a handful of spin-offs and
countless DLC expansions but how does it
all tie together well largely it's
pretty linear what's not so
straightforward is that the
ever-evolving timeline takes in
everything from corporate conspiracies
and human cloning to the American
president's daughter and well whatever
the hell this is from the convoluted
creation of the umbrella corporation
through to the swampland horror of
Resident Evil 7 via the crowd-pleasing
bolder punchy antics of one Chris
Redfield this is the complete timeline
of Resident Evil ok chronologically
speaking our story kicks off a couple of
years before the creation of umbrella in
1962 Lord Oswald East Spencer
Commission's architect George Trevor to
design and build a certain mansion and
research laboratory in the Arklay
mountains
Trevor finally finishes his math
masterpiece in 1967 and it's a
labyrinthine structure full of locked
doors that make no logical sense in
order to hide the mansion's terrible
secrets forever Spencer being the awful
bastard that he is invites the Trevor
family over to stay and well they never
leave across the swinging 60s he joins
forces with University pal James Marcos
an eccentric millionaire Edward Ashford
on an expedition to locate a legendary
African flower known as the stairway to
the Sun this flower is said to contain
powerful properties and this is
confirmed when the trio extracted the
progenitor virus from it this virus has
the ability to genetically alter
organisms and they immediately transport
it back to the USA our evil trio then
established the umbrella corporation as
a legitimate pharmaceutical company as a
cover for their totally illegitimate
viral research and their ultimate goal
of creating a race of superhumans or at
least that expenses ultimate goal
Ashford becomes increasingly frustrated
with the other two and he makes for
Antarctica to set up his own umbrella
research lab which would later hold the
code Veronica
projects ashford never sees the code
veronica project come to fruition though
as in July 1968 he is injected with the
progenitor virus himself on the orders
of all-round bad egg Spencer and he
swiftly dies he is succeeded by son
Alexander who takes control of the
Antarctica umbrella lab in an effort to
keep his father's work going albeit with
more of a focus on cloning back in the
USA Spencer and Marcus take control of
umbrella facilities in the Arklay
mountains just outside of Raccoon City
Spencer continues his research into the
progenitor virus the lab under the newly
constructed mansion while Marcus is
appointed as director of the newly
founded umbrella training facility
Spencer's plan is to create a race of
superhumans dubbed project Wesker and
this nefarious plan sees umbrella kidnap
a whole load of children to be loyal
foot soldiers to Spencer's cause and
they are brainwashed and injected with
the progenitor virus sadly most of them
die all except a certain Albert Wesker
who will come to be quite familiar with
across this timeline meanwhile in
Antarctica Alexander Ashford's Code
Veronica project is finally complete in
1971 Ashford creates two clones from his
family DNA Alfred and Alexia fast
forward to January 1978 yep the 70s were
seemingly sparse for the resi franchise
and Marcus is making a breakthrough with
his research at the Umbrella training
facility by splicing the progenitor with
leech DNA he creates the t-virus or at
least a strain that doesn't immediately
kill those exposed to it it just turns
them into hideously mutated creatures
not sure which one of those is the
better option of him honest his research
is assisted by two students from the
Umbrella training facility doctors
William Birkin and Albert Wesker but
their work together does not last long
at the end of the school year
umbrella closes the facility down and
Wesker Birkin and the t-virus are all
moved dispensers are clay research lab
suspicious of Spencer's motives
Marcus stays behind with his research
and he continues to experiment on
anything and everything from mammals to
reptiles all of which will pop up as
end-of-level bosses in Resident Evil
zero
the early 1980s are not a good time for
the Ashford family remember Alexia
well she's grown up to become a ten year
old child mastermind and is promptly
appointed the senior researcher at
umbrellas Antartica lab much the
annoyance of 21 year old Wesker keep up
Albert after learning the truth about
their origin as clones Alexia and her
brother Alfred vowed to hunt down and
capture their father which they succeed
in doing in 1983 with Alexander Ashford
in our custody Alexey uses him as a test
subject for her research into a new
version of the t-virus known as the t
veronica virus believe it or not the
experiment turns him into a psychotic
monster later known as nas ferati no not
that one taking the failed experiment on
the chin Alexi uses the data she
obtained on her father to inject herself
with the t veronica virus while she
peacefully sleeps the effects off in a
cryogenic chamber for 15 years don't
worry we'll come back to this mad child
prodigy later on back in the art play
labs research on the virus now headed up
by William Birkin has stalled umbrella
has discovered that 10% of the
population are naturally immune to the
virus and Birkin seps himself the morbid
task of solving this unique problem his
answer comes in the form of a
bio-organic weapon or Bo W for short
known as the hunter which is born
through splicing reptilian and human DNA
with the t-virus Birkins research and
development continues across the 80s and
culminates with the start of a little
project known as the tyrant okay it's
late 1988 and I think it's about time we
catch up with our good pal James Marcus
who slowly been going off the rails with
his own brand of the t-virus research as
an independent researcher Marcus makes
headway by continuing to experiment with
leeches and in some extreme cases his
own staff and he eventually creates his
magnum opus the Queen leech his old mate
oz well Spencer is having none of this
though and seeks to regain control of
the t-virus research by assassinating
Marcus and stealing his work he sends in
a team of umbrella soldiers alongside
Wesker and Birkin and they shoot and
kill Marcus before dumping his body and
his precious Queen leech at a nearby
sewage
I wonder if they'll crop back up in this
story spoilers they do the 90 sees
umbrella expand their operations across
the Arklay mountains and into
neighboring Raccoon City with Birkin
making significant progress with his
research creating the superior G virus
in the process
Spencer Commission's a gigantic
underground lab to be built underneath
the city a job that he covers up by
bribing Raccoon City Police Chief Brian
Irons Brian's fast forward to 1996 and
the Raccoon City Police Department
instigate the inaugural special tactics
and Rescue Services Unit or stars for
sure although it's under the
jurisdiction of the our PD it remains a
privately funded independent venture
named Lisa umbrella can keep their
fingers in the pie disgusting during
this time Albert Wesker is assigned to
stars by umbrella and he quickly becomes
the captain of the squads Alpha Team
okay we have finally arrived at the most
pivotal year in our resident evil
timeline 1998 a year that our whopping
five games from the franchise take place
in in May 1998 there is a catastrophic
outbreak of the t-virus at the Spencer
mansion labs and a handful of Cerberus
zombie dogs - you and me escape into the
Arklay mountains and start killing
unfortunate hikers in an attempt to
contain the outbreak umbrella locks down
the mansion lab and the t-virus begins
to spread among the poor staff still
there naturally with the horrific nature
of the art clay killings the stories
emerging inspire a media firestorm and
the press start putting pressure on the
RPD to get the situation under control
chief irons dispatches the stars alpha
and Bravo teams to investigate the
surrounding mountains with Wesker
overseeing the missions unbeknownst to
the rest of his teams though Wesker's
directive from umbrella HQ is instead to
gain critical information about the
site's POWs and destroy the mansion
before it's discovered alongside that he
is ordered to gather information about
the Bo w's combat ability specifically
in their interactions with the incoming
stars teams
and so we finally reached the very first
game in the resident evil timeline which
details the Stars Bravo teams failed
mission the Bravo team make their way
out to the Arklay mountains only for
their helicopter to crash on route
courtesy of a little bit of sabotage
from our good mate Wesker instead of
making for the Spencer mansion as per
their original plan the team stumble
onto the wreck of a military convoy with
all the soldiers very much dead they
discovered that the troop had been
escorting accused murderer Billy Cohen
and putting two and two together and
making five assume Billy is the lad
responsible for all the brutal killings
they split up and rookie stars member
Rebecca Jambres quickly discovers an
abandoned train the ecliptic Express now
remember I said that James Marcus and
his prize Queen leach would make a
comeback into this story well boy what a
comeback it is it turns out that when
umbrella dumped Marcus and his leech in
that sewage facility the leech slowly
ate away at Marcus's body and mind
effectively absorbing his personality
the end result was a reincarnated Marcus
leach hybrid thing hell-bent on revenge
with umbrella this franchise is [ __ ]
mad and I loved it with Marcus back from
the dead he goes to town on the train
and by the time hapless Rebecca chambers
stumbles onto the Train they are all
dead or Undead I guess having been
consumed by Marcus's army of leeches
Rebecca boards the Train encounters
death row inmate Billy Cohen and they
start to investigate the Express keen to
get the train back on its journey Wesker
and Burkean send in a team of umbrella
soldiers who succeed in getting the
train underway and promptly get chomped
by the leeches Rebecca and Billy managed
to bring the train to a stop or be a
messy one and emerge from the wreckage
at the Umbrella training facility Marcus
or the hybrid leeched thing reveals
himself to Wesker and Birkin and this
leads the duo to activate the facility's
self-destruct function caught in the
middle of all this are poor Rebecca and
Billy who navigate their way out of the
facility killed the Queen leech and get
to safety before the place blows
sky-high
as they overlook the destruction Rebecca
allows the actually innocent Billy to go
free and she leaves him to go and help
Alpha Team at a familiar-looking mansion
the game then ends with Billy giving the
cheesiest thumbs up I've ever seen okay
we are now with the og Resident Evil
which details the exploits of Alpha Team
in their mission to investigate the
Arklay killings headed up by Wesker the
star Squad includes expert marksman
Chris Redfield Jill Valentine the master
of unlocking top explosives lad Barry
Burton and helicopter pilot Brad vicars
among others the team successfully land
near the mansion but are quickly caught
off guard by a pack of zombie dogs which
forces them into the Spencer mansion
separated they each make their way
through the illogical maze of corridors
encountering and surviving the zombified
umbrella staff bo w's and various other
mutations meanwhile Wesker is pulling
the strings behind the scenes he
strong-arms barry into helping him set
traps for the rest of the stars team by
threatening to kill his family Chris and
Jill survive everything and anything
that's thrown at them sharks snakes
spiders bad dialogue and they meet up
with Rebecca chambers on their way to
getting out of the mansion Wesker is
finally revealed to be a traitor to
alpha team and as a result he releases
umbrellas tyrant project a huge mutated
man mountain not that one in a bid to
kill the remaining stars members Chris
Jill and Rebecca fight off the tyrant
and thanks to the impeccable timing of
vicar's return with the helicopter they
all escape as the Spencer mansion
self-destructs there's definitely a
pattern emerging here right amidst the
chaos Wesker manages to survive as well
albeit without the critical Bo W samples
he intended to gather and he leaves
umbrella for good
a couple of months pass and we catch up
with Jill Valentine during the events of
resident evil 3 nemesis under pressure
from umbrella stars as being disbanded
and nobody believes a team about what
they saw in the arc plane mountains the
t-virus has very much arrived in
downtown Raccoon City having spread from
that gigantic underground lab that
somehow remains secret with the zombie
population on the rise there is chaos in
the streets and the RPD is quickly
overwhelmed umbrella in a series of
questionable decisions starts deploying
Bo w's all across Raccoon City chief
among them the dapper mr. X and the
titular foe of resi 3 nemesis nemesis is
given the mission of hunting down former
stars members and keeping the momentum
going
nemesis begins his unrelenting chase of
Jill Valentine across town the umbrella
biohazard countermeasure service god
that's a mouthful arrive and start
evacuating anyone who's not a zombie in
her attempts to escape Jill runs into
you BCS team member Carlos Oliviero and
the pair take the fight to nemesis while
trying to escape the ruins of the city
during their fight Jill becomes infected
with the g-virus leaving poor Carlos to
fend for himself and find a cure for
Jill will she survive you'll have to
wait till later to find out because
we've got a date with a blonde hunk
taking place concurrently with resident
evil 3 is the campaign to Resident Evil
2 which sees new cop on the block Leon
Kennedy and Chris Redfield sister Claire
appear for the first time in the
franchise Leon arrives in Raccoon City
for his first day on the job in the
middle of the zombie apocalypse after
encountering Claire Redfield who's
searching for her brother Chris at an
out-of-town gas station the pair make
their way into the heart of the city
before getting separated during a car
accident
Leon eventually makes his way to the RPD
which is completely overrun with zombies
after navigating the station's bizarre
lock and key setup it is an old museum
after all
Leon finds himself down in the cells
where he runs into the mysterious Ada
Wong ADA's mission is to swipe a vial of
the g-virus and Leon agrees to go along
with it the naive hearthrob as they're
investigating the pair are attacked by
mr. X and they escape into the sewers
where they encounter Annette Birkin wife
of umbrella scientist William Annette
injures ADA in informs Leon that he's
working with a mercenary who wants to
sell the virus on the black market
Leon the fool that he is descends into
Birkins lab anyway swipes the g-virus
and returns to Ada who immediately holds
him up at gunpoint for it a net pops up
one last time
shoots Ada and in the ensuing chaos the
g-virus and ADA fall into the abyss as
Leon tries to escape the lab mr. X makes
one last encore before being dispatched
by a handy rocket launcher that is
thrown to him by ADA who has
miraculously survived her fall meanwhile
Claire encounters a young girl sherry
daughter of William Birkin and they
managed to escape a giant creature by
taking refuge in the RPD car park where
they meet morally bankrupt police chief
Bryan irons Bryan's Bryan kidnaps sherry
and locks her in a neighboring abandoned
orphanage as Claire mounts a rescue
mission
a tyrant drops in on ions infecting him
with a parasite ion's dies and sherry
flees while Claire manages to escape
into the sewers only to bump into
Sherry's mom annette who reveals that
the creature chasing her daughter is in
fact her mutated father turns out our
will had plans to sell his g-virus
creation to the US military
a plan that didn't go down too well with
umbrella who promptly sent in a team to
kill him
to save himself Birkin injected himself
with the g-virus turning the good doctor
into a repulsive monster in the ensuing
carnage he destroyed a bunch of t-virus
stores which led to the Raccoon City
outbreak when Claire and Annette find
sherry they discover that she's already
been infected by her father and the
payer hatch a plan to find a cure from
within Birkins labs Claire succeeds in
finding an antidote and in the chaos of
getting back to cure sherry and net is
killed by her husband naturally the
whole facility in acts the contractually
obligated self-destruct function and
Claire and sherry escape to an
evacuation train where they meet back up
with Lian Birkin has one more crack at
killing them fails and is then caught in
the fires of the exploding labs okay
let's wrap up that cliffhanger from
earlier Carlos being the absolute lad
that he is scavenge is a cure for Jill
because by this stage they're just lying
around the waist of Raccoon City and she
recovers from her infection the pair
make their way through a series of
underground umbrella labs in an attempt
to escape the city before it's noot from
the air it's the only way to be sure
enroute they're ambushed by good old
nemesis one last time and Jill fires the
killing blow with the biggest of big
[ __ ] guns
after defeating nemesis and overpowering
Juana Carlos is corrupt squadmates
the pair ride off into the sunset and
Raccoon City is reduced to ashes behind
them all right three months of passed
since the devastation in Raccoon City
and Claire Redfield is still searching
for her brother Chris her search takes
her to an umbrella facility in Paris
where she is eventually caught in a
sequence heavily riffing on jang-woo
umbrella locks her up an isolated prison
in the Southern Ocean known as rock for
island and lo and behold there is an
outbreak of the t-virus on the island
and Claire soon gets set free soon after
she encounters the world's most
irritating Canadian a floppy haired lad
called Steve Burnside and the pair team
up to escape the island in their way
stands alfred Ashford one of the clones
created by umbrella co-founder Alexander
Ashford and well he's gone a bit insane
his time alone and apart from his twin
sister Alexia has led him to cultivate a
split personality and he switches
frequently between the identities of
himself and Alexia Claire and Steve soon
break free from rock for Ireland only
for Alfred to divert their plane to the
nearby umbrella facility in Antarctica
using the system's autopilot override
crash landing in Antarctica the pair
finally defeat Alfred who uses his final
spark of life to awaken his sister
Alexia from her cryo sleep she's not the
only Ashford in Antarctica though turns
out popper Alexander Ashford the other
Nosferatu is still around and he's
hungry for a revenge as Claire squares
off against the hideous remains of
Alexander Alexia takes control of the
situation and captures our heroic trio
as they attempt to escape meanwhile back
on Roquefort Island Chris has turned up
searching for his sister any search of
the island he bumps into none other than
dr. Albert Wesker who has gone rogue
from umbrella since the Spencer mansion
incident and is there to retrieve a
sample of the tea Veronica virus with
their goals both in Antarctica the pair
separately make haste for the umbrella
base once there Chris saves Claire poor
Steve becomes infected and dies Alexia
is finally defeat
and that sneaky bastard Wesker makes off
with Steve Steve Veronica virus riddled
body
all while umbrellas Antartica base yeah
you guessed it self-destructs okay next
up is the we liked gun spin-off Resident
Evil darkside Chronicles well the
majority of darkside Chronicles is a
retelling of Resident Evil 2 and code
Veronica there is one new mission in its
campaign that keeps our timeline ticking
along and that is operation Xavier four
years after the disastrous events in
Raccoon City Leon Kennedy and special
ops member Jack krauser are dispatched
to South America to apprehend cartel
leader Xavier Hidalgo who was apparently
infected his daughter Manuela with the
Veronica virus Leon and Krauser
encounter and secure Manuela before
proceeding to head algos complex there
they defeat Xavier who has fused himself
with the Veronica virus to become some
kind of giant killer plant and they
escaped with Manuela via helicopter
during the fight krauser's arm is
wounded and becomes infected and as a
result he's discharged from the US Army
this leads him down a darker path as he
contacts resi Big Bad Albert Wesker to
join his team Umbrella Chronicles is
next in our timeline and it largely
retreads ground from Resident Evil 0 1 &
3 but like darkside Chronicles it has a
unique mission called umbrellas end and
I'm guessing you can figure out what
that entails the year is 2003 Chris
Redfield and Jill Valentine are
investigating umbrellas last known
stronghold a facility in Russia which is
developing a new Bo W known as the Talos
project Chris and Jill being the experts
that they are infiltrate the facility
and destroy the Talos but wait who's
that on the horizon it's only bloody
Wesker again here to take his final
revenge on umbrella Wesker flings his
coat into the camera like an absolute
nutter it must be freezing out there and
tears his way into the compound he
encounters sergey vladimirovich
to keep umbrella going in the wake at
the raccoon city outbreaks Sir Guy is no
match for Wesker who quickly dispatches
him and steals umbrellas deepest darkest
secrets which he then makes public as a
result umbrella loses its
long-standing legal battle with the US
government a dispute that's been going
on since 1998 an umbrella declares
bankruptcy as a result nothing more
exciting than court proceedings to bring
an evil monster creating corporation to
its knees a lads with umbrella a thing
of the past Resident Evil for kicks off
a new era for the franchise in thrilling
style resi 4 is a largely self-contained
chapter in the franchise taking the
series away from its zombified roots the
year is 2004 and Leon Kennedy is
dispatched to rescue the American
president's daughter Ashley from a
mysterious cult in deepest darkest Spain
he arrives at a creepy rural farmstead
populated by a group of hostile villages
who have pledged their agents to the
cult of los Illuminatus the villages are
effectively being controlled by a
parasite known as las Plagas with the
cults leader Osman Sadler calling the
shots Leon after surviving chainsaws
giants and a mutated whale finally
tracks down Ashley to a nearby church
and the pair later escape to a castle
which doesn't look menacing in the
slightest jokes it's under the control
of creepy manchild Ramon Salazar another
of Sadler's henchmen when Leon and now
she gets separated amidst the castles
deadly traps Leon encounters an old
acquaintance the lady in the red dress
Ada Wong long time
Leon battles his way out of the castle
killing a mutated Salazar and makes his
way to find Ashley at an offshore island
facility old acquaintances are like
London buses it seems as Leon then bumps
into his former Special Ops buddy Jack
krauser krauser reveals that he and ADA
are both working for Wesker to secure
the Las Plagas parasite and Leon being
the good egg boy they is defeats him
Leon then confronts Sadler himself
killing him atop the islands research
facility with a good old-fashioned
rocket launcher to the face
courtesy again of ADA ADA then holds
Leon up at gunpoint again and she makes
off with a sample of the Las Plagas
virus meanwhile Leon and Ashley escape
the island self-destruct sequence on jet
skis Resident Evil 4 what game
Resident Evil Revelations takes place
smack bang between rezzie's four and
five and introduces the bioterrorism
security assessment alliance or BSA a
into the mix god resi really loves its
acronyms in the wake of a bioterrorism
attack that destroys the city of Tara
Grisha BSAA
agents Jill Valentine and Parker Luciani
are dispatched to the last known
location of their missing team members
Chris Redfield who's now got massive
arms and Jessica Shara watt that
last-known location
turns out to be the Queen Zenobia
Cruiser which is drifting in the
Mediterranean Sea seemingly abandoned
while there Jill and Parker are ambushed
by an organization called the Veltro the
folks responsible for the previous bio
attacks and they are imprisoned the BSAA
makes contact with Chris why do they do
that in the first place and sends him
and Jessica in to rescue Jill and Parker
and they make for the Zenobia Chris and
Jill eventually reunite because that's
what everyone really wants and foil a
plot to contaminate the sea with a virus
known as the t abyss at some point
they're just gonna run out of names for
these viruses fast forward a year and
Dream Team Chris and Jill have finally
tracked down the last remaining umbrella
co-founder Lord oz well Spencer in a
nice little nod to the original game
Jill the master of unlocking uses a
lockpick to break into Spencer's
residence and the duo make their way
through the mansion until they encounter
not Spencer but Wesker having arrived
ahead of them Wesker brutally murders
Spencer by just punching him right
through the chest it it's just
devastating Wesker then squares off
against Chris and Jill and as the battle
comes to its conclusion Jill rugby
tackles Wesker out of a window and they
both plummet down a cliff did they
survive of course they did Wesker
cryogenically freezes Jill in
preparation for
yeah we're heading to Africa for
resident evil 5 which takes place nearly
three years later the game follows Chris
Redfield and BSAA partner Shiva Alomar
as they investigate an outbreak of the
Las Plagas parasite in an African town
Chris and Sheva stop an illegal arms
deal and as a result stumble onto
evidence that Jill is still alive driven
to find his old partner Chris continues
the investigation and the pair find
themselves in the cave that started this
whole franchise off in the first place
yeah they rediscovered the origins of
the t-virus the stairway to the Sun
flower and uncover a conspiracy
involving the bsas parent company try
sell who have been sneaky continuing on
with umbrellas research Chris and Sheva
eventually catch up to Jill Valentine
sporting a new blonde hair car and
wrestle her in order to remove a
mind-control device that is attached to
her chest to absolutely no one surprise
Wesker reveals himself with another
world destroying plan this time it's
firing missiles containing a virus known
as Ouroboros all around the world
our trio chase Wesker down and
eventually corner him in an active
volcano because by this point why the
[ __ ] not
Chris and Sheva take the fight to Wesker
and in Chris's case some poor innocent
defenseless boulders that probably had
friends and family that cared for them
and they eventually kill Wesker once and
for all by firing yet you guessed it
ladies and gentlemen it's the crowd
favorite ready big bad color an RPG
right into his smug face
next up on the timeline is Resident Evil
Revelations 2 a game whose story was
heavily inspired by czech author Franz
Kafka a fact that I literally just found
out while writing this timeline to make
my job even more complicated revelations
2 takes place across two different
timelines
the first sees Claire Redfield and Moira
Burton daughter of ginger legend Barrie
being kidnapped and imprisoned on shoosh
shoosh Tov shoosh Tov Annie an island by
a mysterious woman known as the overseer
in a weird Kafka esque experiment of
sorts
the prisoners are fitted with bracelets
that track their fear levels get too
afraid and you turn into a monster
symbolism the second the second time
line however sees Barry arrived on the
island in an attempt to rescue his
daughter a whopping six months later the
story then unfolds over four episodes
each of them named after a Kafka short
story and follows Claire and Maura's
attempt to escape and Barry's rescue
mission Barry encounters a little girl
known as Natalia who reveals that the
overseer is in fact Alex Wesker contrary
to belief not a sister to Albert Wesker
but another child that has survived
umbrellas heinous project Wesker to
Wesker's you've gotta reach the quarter
finally managed to escape the island if
you got the good ending that is and
defeat Alex with oh boy is that oh yes
it is it's back the most classic of
Resident Evil mad man murdering weapons
the rocket launcher
oh my god where do I even start with
Resident Evil 6 playing like a greatest
hits of the franchise Resident Evil 6
features a bloated monster of a
storyline with not one not two not even
bloody three but four different
campaigns and seven major characters the
story kicks off on Christmas Eve 2012
with Jake Muller the son of the late
Albert Wesker hang on when did he get
busy
yeah Wesker Fox being taken into custody
by a grown-up Cherie Birkin who is now a
BSAA agent Muller is the key to creating
a vaccine to the new C virus but Birkins
mission to extract him from the
fictional country Adonia is put on hold
when they are hunted down by a new bio
weapon called booster nack which is like
nemesis on steroids to add insult to
injury during the attack they are
abducted by an imposter calling herself
a door one meanwhile bsaa agents Chris
Redfield and piers Nivens are in the
same neighborhood to keep the local
infected population under control they
soon come under attack from a new
organization calling itself neo umbrella
supposedly led by ADA one and their
whole squad is wiped out by the C virus
fast forward six months and the American
president is about to air umbrellas
dirty laundry from the 1998 Raccoon City
outbreaks filthy laundry that implicates
the US government as much as it does
umbrella but there's another
bioterrorism attack and the president is
infected forcing her old friend Leon
Kennedy to kill him Leon uncovers that
the National Security Advisor Derek
Simmons was behind the attack and he
tracks down Simmons to a neo umbrella
lab in Lang Jie and China with his
partner helena harper christen pays are
then dispatched to liang sheyang to hunt
down ada
and they come into contact with Leon and
Helena who informed them that the ADA
that they are hunting is in fact a clone
following their running with Kris Leon
and Helena finally confront and defeat a
mutated Simmons Leon then dispatches
Kris and piers to an oil rig to rescue
Jake and sherry and prevent another
large scale bioterrorism attack this
time courtesy of a bio weapon called hey
this kitchen sink approach to
storytelling all dovetails into a messy
conclusion that sees peers inject
himself with the C virus to defeat house
Sheri and Jake killed the behemoth
booster knack and the real Aida destroys
the lab where her clone was created whoa
that was a lot and so we reached the
final leg on our Resident Evil journey
the events leading up to the swampland
horror of Resident Evil 7 the year is
2014 and all hell is about to break
loose for the Baker family after
encountering an abandoned tanker in the
Louisiana bio Jack Baker finds a little
girl and brings her back to the family
home all appears normal into the girl
wakes up and causes the Baker's to go
well fast forward three years to the
summer of 2017 for the main plot of
Resident Evil 7 which sees poor Ethan
winters encounter the charming Baker
family while he searches for his missing
wife Mia as Ethan enjoys the delightful
hospitality of the Baker's he soon
discovers that his wife and the family
have been infected with a mold like
fungus that turns them super aggressive
he escapes the hellish residence with
help from the Baker's daughter Zoe
defeating Jack and his wife margarita
along the way Ethan eventually discovers
that his wife Mia was working as an
operative for an organization that
developed the little girl known as
Evelyn into a bioweapon Evelyn's escaped
and well you know the rest of the story
Ethan finally encounters Evelyn faced a
giant face eventually killing her before
being rescued by none other than bold a
murderer Chris Redfield
the pair escaped in a helicopter with
Muir if you chose to cure her and they
fly off into the Sun right
wait is that an umbrella logo on the
side of that helicopter well sort of in
the wake of umbrellas messy end another
company known as blue umbrella
emerged from the ashes with the primary
goal to clean up the mess of the
original corporation in the wake of the
Baker residents outbreak Chris Redfield
assists blue umbrella in capturing Lucas
the last remaining Baker before he
reveals the secrets of Evelyn's
infection two nefarious ne'er-do-wells
/ and there you go the resident evil
timeline in a hideous hideous nutshell
there are a couple of avenues of the
franchise that I didn't fully explore
like the Japanese CG movie trilogy or
the mediocre like gun games that came
out on the PlayStation 1 and 2 but if
you're a die-hard Resident Evil fan you
should definitely check them out I hope
you enjoyed this timeline and please let
me know your favorite Resident Evil game
in the comments section below and I'll
see you next time